تظهر بعض الصناعات
الترابط بين الولايات المتحدة والصين
تمامًا مثل صناعة الألعاب ، وتأتي 84 في المائة
من جميع
الألعاب المباعة في الولايات المتحدة من الصين ،
وهذا يعني أن معرض الألعاب هذا العام في
نيويورك كل شخص في نفس
القارب من صانعي  هذه
الكرات المزعجة بالترتر لهذه الأفعى
الجرسية وسيحاولون معرفة كيف ومتى
يمكنهم رسم بياني لإنتاجنا ، لذلك سألت
الرئيس التنفيذي لجمعية الألعاب عن مدى سكون
الأمر حتى نبدأ في رؤية تأثير حقيقي
نحن في  نافذة قصيرة هنا
حيث لا تسبب ضررًا كبيرًا إذا
استمر ذلك حتى أبريل ، فستبدأ
في التأثير على عمليات التسليم الصيفية
للألعاب الصيفية ، وبعد ذلك بالطبع إذا
تجاوزت ذلك الحد ، فإننا نتحدث
عن العطلات ،
ينتهي الأمر بمعظم ألعاب الكريسماس  في المحيط خلال
فصل الصيف ، يصل أواخر الصيف إلى هنا في
الخريف وينتهي به الأمر في مستودعات Walmart Target
وأشياء من هذا القبيل
بعد فترة وجيزة لا تنس أن هذه
الصناعة قضت معظم العام الماضي
قلقة بشأن التهديد  من التعريفات
الآن ، تم تجنب تلك التي كانت ستضرب الألعاب
مباشرة قبل
عيد الميلاد مباشرةً كجزء من صفقة تجارية للمرحلة الأولى
لكن الرئيس التنفيذي لهذه الشركة
Learning Resources الذي يصنع
روبوتات التشفير هذه عندما أخبرني أن
التحضير لتلك التعريفات
يساعدهم بالفعل  الآن ، لدينا دائمًا
مخزون مرتفع بسبب التعريفات الجمركية في
العام الماضي ، تم تخزين الكثير من شركات الألعاب بما في ذلك
شركتنا ، وبالتالي لدينا أكثر من
كمية عادية من المخزون ، فقط
حظًا سعيدًا ، أفترض ، لذلك لا أتوقع أن
أرى نقصًا في العديد  أشهر على
أساس جاد في سيناريو أسوأ حالة ،
كل هذا أدى إلى
سؤال أساسي لهذه الصناعة ، هل هم
معرضون جدًا للصين جيدًا ، حيث يحاول صانعو هذه
اللعبة التي تربط بين آخرين
إعادة الإنتاج إلى الولايات المتحدة ،
لكنها  يستغرقون وقتًا كما يقولون
ويصعب العثور على العمالة المناسبة ، لذا في
هذه الأثناء تواجه هذه الصناعة
فترة أخرى من عدم اليقين
باستيان سي إن إن نيويورك